Shure: 先糊弄糊弄得了哪天买的时候
Shure: 就一次领虽然
Shure: Just get everything at once, although...
Shure: 但是他真的很好用不符合我们的理念
Shure: But it's really useful, it doesn't align with our idea.
Lucia: 因为一个抹布的话
Lucia: Because if it's just one cloth...
Lucia: 感觉可能擦整个擦不太干净所以我本来说
Lucia: It might not clean everything well, so I was saying...
Lucia: 光把边上大家用到的地方擦一下
Lucia: Just wipe the areas everyone uses.
Alice: 你不饿了吗
Alice: Aren't you hungry?
Alice: 你吃吧
Alice: You go ahead and eat.
Tasha: 我不敢吃
Tasha: 啊不好意思
Tasha: Oh, sorry.
Shure:  没事我们是一个
Alice: 别做啊现在这个脏
Alice: Don't do it, it's dirty now.
Lucia: 这确实还有还有仨
Lucia: There are still three more.
Lucia: 那要不再拿一个用好了
Lucia: Should we get another one to use?
Lucia: 如果万一要用来洗碗的话
Lucia: In case we need to wash dishes.
Tasha:为什么6个人只点4杯饮料
Tasha: Why did we only order 4 drinks for 6 people?
Katrina:  我不喝
Katrina: I don't drink.
Tasha: 你不喝嗯
Tasha: You don't drink, huh?
Katrina: 我不能喝冰的
Katrina: I can't drink cold stuff.
Tasha: 啊你也不喝
Tasha: Oh, you don't drink either?
Katrina: 我不是我来大姨妈了来不了对所以我才睡那么死
Tasha: 你是这几天
Tasha: It's that time for you?
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina:  直接睡晕过去了
Katrina: 摆筷然后摆拍一张
Katrina: Let's set up the chopsticks and take a picture.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Alice: 今天是疯狂星期四的一半
Alice: Today is half Crazy Thursday.
Shure: 今天是Tuesday吗
Shure: Is today Tuesday?
Alice:对Tuesday
Shure: 哦锡克内克day
Shure: Oh, it's Sick-Nick day.
Jake:KFC Tuesady
Jake:疯狂星期二
Katrina:  嗯我手机
Katrina: Hmm, my phone...
Shure:  为什么你手机放我手上
Shure: Why is your phone in my hand?
Katrina: 我不知道啊哈哈哈哈
Katrina: I don't know, haha.
Katrina: 为什么会在你手上
Katrina: Why is it in your hand?
Katrina: 我喝旺仔牛奶吧  Shure: 好嘞
Katrina: I'll drink Want Want milk. Shure: Okay.
Jake: 我来我来搞一搞
Jake: I'll take it. I'll take it.
Lucia: 没事没事没事
Jake:还有多少  Lucia: 呃差不多了
Jake: How much is left? Tasha: Uh, almost done.
Lucia: 刚才那个硕就是把这边已经擦了一遍
Lucia: 有时候反应不过来
Lucia: Sometimes I can't react quickly enough.
Lucia: 他的全名
Lucia: His full name.
Katrina: 这是什么
Katrina: What is this?
Tasha:这个名字还是很好记的
Tasha: This name is still easy to remember.
Katrina: 披萨
Katrina: Pizza.
Tasha: 这凳子是不是也得也得  啊小心
Tasha: Does this chair also need... ah, be careful.
Tasha: 为什么不点肯德基的蛋挞
Tasha: Why not order KFC egg tarts?
Lucia: 让我看看这凳子脏不脏
Lucia: Let me see if this chair is dirty.
Lucia: 哎好吧凳子也挺脏的
Lucia: Oh well, the chair is pretty dirty too.
Jake:这个闻所未闻的肯德基长成这个样子
Jake:肯德基长烤鸭
Lucia: 那边我把那两个凳子擦一下
Lucia: Over there, I'll wipe those two chairs.
Jake:肯德基披萨
Jake: KFC pizza.
Katrina: 肯德基的
Katrina: KFC pizza.
Jake: 笑话外国人
Jake:他们点的肯德基是什么
Katrina: 他们的肯德基跟我们不太一样是吧
Katrina: Their KFC is not quite the same as ours, right?
Alice: 这是中式的有骨有骨鸭
Alice: This is Chinese-style bone-in duck.
Lucia: 对肯德基麦当劳新品好像国内外都不太一样吧
Lucia: Right, KFC and McDonald's new items seem different domestically and abroad.
Alice: 有骨鸭米花
Alice: Bone-in duck popcorn.
Tasha: 呃口感也不一样
Tasha: Uh, the taste is also different.
Katrina:  夹了那种什么辣的，辣椒酱的那种鸡肉卷
Katrina: Stuffed with some spicy, chili sauce chicken wrap.
Jake: 国内的肯德基麦当劳
Jake: Domestic KFC and McDonald's.
Lucia:这些放着一会要用
Lucia: Put these aside, we'll need them later.
Katrina:  吃呗  Jake:坐啊
Katrina: Let's eat. Jake: Sit down.
Alice: 中式鸭肉卷笑死  Katrina: 这是土豆泥吗
Alice: Chinese-style duck wrap, so funny.  Katrina: Is this mashed potatoes?
Alice: 哎是不是凳子不太够
Alice: Hey, are there not enough chairs?
Lucia: 正好6个
Lucia: Exactly six.
Lucia: 但是那边那边的还没来得及没来得及擦啊
Lucia: But over there, I haven't had time to wipe them yet.
Alice: 这是没擦吧
Alice: This one hasn't been wiped, right?
Jake:没擦擦一下
Jake: No, wipe it.
Alice: 抹布
Lucia: 这这4个都擦过了刚才
Lucia: These four were just wiped earlier.
Lucia: 那另外的还没来得及擦啊
Lucia: Haven't had time to wipe the others yet.
Alice: 这根本就擦不干净
Alice: This just can't be cleaned off.
Shure: 行了
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 行吗
Shure: Is that okay?
Jake:呃 行吧 吃汉堡咱就不拍了
Jake:吃汉堡这个不太重要
Jake:停停停